I had of course the models of great
writers and many very important for me
was the case of flow Barre for example
and the reason was that unlike other
writers who seemed genius since they
were born
forever had to work a lot in his life to
achieve master wharves so in in his case
talent was something that was the result
of perseverance discipline the will to
be a good writer and when I I i love
prover since I've read his his first
novel which was Madame Bovary I read a
lot about his life and and I discovered
that when he started he was not a genius
at all that he was a very let's say
common writer who wrote under the
influence of his models and and that his
originality and and and really his
talent is something that he achieved
through discipline and and very very
hard work so that gave me the let's say
kind of methods for writing which I
think was very very important because I
felt that I was not a genius at all so
that I wanted to to write good books I
had to work and and flerbert was a great
inspiration because he was a writer that
had built his talent his genius
through very very hard work to a very
deep commitment with his vocation with
what he wanted to achieve so he helped
me enormously not only by the beauty and
the richness of of his books but also
because he managed not been a born
genius to build his genius through
effort commitment perseverance
discipline